breaking tonight michael cohen president
Trump's former attorney is claiming the
president knew in advance about that
Trump Tower meeting back in June 2016
and which Russians were supposedly going
to offer campaign dirt on Hillary
Clinton that according to CNN of course
and all their breathless coverage they
seem to be ignoring the important nugget
quote to be clear these sources said
Cohen does not have evidence such as
audio recordings to corroborate his
claim but he is willing to attest to his
account here now to react former US
Attorney and Fox News contributor Andy
McCarthy and Wall Street Journal
columnist Kim straw so welcome to both
of you Andy let's start with you here
boy it seems like Michael Cohen's gotten
very talkative wants a lot of stuff
coming out over the last few days what
do you make of this latest claim well I
think it's a he's had a change in
posture over the last number of weeks
the retention on Lanny Davis certainly
was an indicator that I think the big
problem he'll have if this is actually
his version of events is apparently he
has talked about this before in Prior
testimony and prior interviews and
evidently did not call this up I've
always thought that if Muller believed
that Cohen was somehow the key to
proving a collusion case against Trump
there's no way he lets that case walk to
the Southern District of New York so I'd
be surprised if this links up to
anything that's serious in the way of
collusion like an espionage conspiracy
but look the Trump Tower meeting is bad
it's not collusion in the sense that
they were that they open the
investigation over but nobody look good
at this yeah Andy as we talked about
this I think we've we forget Hillary
Clinton paid for dirt yeah that was
assembled by the Russians and in the
form of the steel dossier so she
actually went further than meeting with
someone hurt people paid for it they got
dirt and then it ended up making its way
all the way through the US government
Laura it's a big deal you know well you
know look I don't think that it's bad if
campaigns are turning to foreign
governments for dirt it's not collude
it's not something that's impeachable
it's a key but that's what this is
Kimberly let's go to you on this Rudy
Giuliani was on CNN as this came out and
he had a comment about the well the
veracity of mr. Cohen let's watch
there's nobody that I know that knows
him that hasn't warned me that if he's
back he's up against the wall he'll pull
like crazy because he's alive all his
life Wow war of words that seems like
we'll probably only stoke Cohen to
release more information well just the
kind of guy you want as a lawyer right
but look I think the issue here is first
you got to decide whether or not you
believe the CNN reporting and there has
been a lot of breathless reporting out
there that has turned out not to be
correct then even if it is correct you
have to decide if you believe mr. Cohen
now versus what as Andy said he might
have said in the past and whether or not
there's any evidence which apparently
there is not in which case this may come
down to a case of he said versus three
other he said saying the opposite but I
mean what Andy said is true it kind of
looks icky but I think the bigger point
here is is there a crime and it's
obviously was not a crime for Trump jr.
to meet with this Russian national and
find out what she had to talk about it's
also not a crime for mr. Trump to have
had prior knowledge of it either mr.
Trump senior the president the question
is is er under oath said that he didn't
know was he in any situation where he
might be viewed as having lied to
federal law enforcement I'm not really
sure that's the case so it's another
potentially bad headline if it's true
but I'm not necessarily sure it's any
legal jeopardy and Andy this vasila it's
a woman was was there to push the
Magnitsky act like she was trying to get
him to push Congress on that Magnitsky
act because of Russian adoptions well I
mean the whole thing was do with Hillary
so it was a big scam big play and they
were all sounds like they were all
played in that meeting Jared was bored
they think he got up and walked out or
manna fort walked out and so it was a
big nothing but if
is where they are now Andy I'm on this
level and we're gonna get to the Twitter
issue in a moment what does this tell
you about the state of the Muller
investigation it seems to me that the
Mahler investigation is winding down to
a conclusion that investigation or that
indictment that they brought recently
against the twelve Russians who are
actually intelligence officers I don't
think that's the kind of thing that you
should indict but putting that aside if
you read the indictment and the logic of
it it kind of excludes the possibility
that there could have been the kind of
espionage conspiracy that everybody was
so whipped up about that caused the
investigation to start in the first
place and led to Muller's appointment so
if it is winding down I sure hope it's
winding down because it's like it ought
to yeah this report out today that
Muller is looking through the
president's tweets yeah well who thought
he wasn't I've been looking at them too
cam if you've been looking at them play
this for you guys because Preet Bharara
of course former US Attorney Southern
District
Preet Bharara was on CNN today with Wolf
Blitzer and they were all excited about
this tweet story let's watch the tweets
that he sends late at night and early in
the morning and often out of anger I
think goes some way to showing what his
State of Mind was and to prove
obstruction I'm quoting Giuliani now if
you're going to obstruct justice you do
it quietly and secretly not in public
what are you making them well you know
yes what Rudy Giuliani says is the norm
this president likes to break norms and
maybe he likes to violate the law in a
way that breaks forms as well Kimberly
the cheerleading here is extraordinary
but we have been witnessing this now for
going on two years and and as I just
said headline after headline saying oh
definitely collusion and then no
obstruction of justice and really it
will only be a few weeks now and look
what Muller is looking at this point and
nothing has come of it so far other than
those indictments we've had relate
to charges that have nothing to do with
either of those two central topics or
anything that the press is actively
pressing for so I mean I agree with Andy
I would wish that if Muller has decided
that the he has decided that Trump is
not a target that he's not going down
the road that even if he's still
wrapping up his probe that he'd feel
he'd had a duty to tell the country the
president is no longer a target so that
people can start to move on and eat
early said earlier today that you know
if this is where they are looking over
tweets then this is just like the dryn
just like this is it's just ridiculous
I'm sorry now we're at tweets and what
you know the interviews this is all
public somehow do you how are you
obstructing an investigation with public
comments I don't I'm not following that
I guess impossible but I don't follow
that yeah but see the whole thing Laura
is preposterous because you know with
due respect to pre you have state of
mind or criminal state of mind is
irrelevant unless you've done something
that actually can amount to obstruction
the president cannot obstruct justice by
taking lawful actions that are within
his constitutional prerogatives like
pardoning people or way or a firing
Comey are weighing in on whether
somebody should be prosecuted which
prosecutors across this country do every
day or or or complaining that Jeff
Sessions didn't recuse him recuse
himself right abstracting John it's an
opinion no it's a yeah I understand the
style problem like they don't like the
way Trump goes about things but you
still gotta kind of like prove the thing
that's a crime before you start worrying
about what somebody stay to mind was
yeah but a former US attorney in New
York like prepar I should know better I
mean yeah you know I know he's on CNN
but you gotta know but you can't say
that on television fantastic
conversation guys thanks so much